de l'imprimante de portrait en trois
dimensions au jeu interactif coloré
inventeur en tout genre se sont donné
rendez-vous à la commanderie pour ce
tout premier vêlage des futurs insolite
on est venu présenter quelques brevets
français c'est une première on est
enthousiaste l'avenir parmi autant de
monde ici
tout juste rentré de la foire de paris
ceux qui campent inc adaptable à tous
véhicules utilitaires attire le public
pouvait les piloter les orienter les
mettre dans le sens que vous voulez les
recruter à nouveau pour pouvoir leur
foncer et voilà ce qui vous permet
vraiment de créer des aménagements
nouveau en très peu de temps sans
contrainte et sans outillage
plus loin un réfrigérateur d'extérieur
pour conserver au frais vos livraisons
alimentaires en cas d'absence
donc là il va pouvoir taper un code à 4
chiffres
il ouvre la box
qui est éclairée à l'intérieur et qui
donne une température entre 2 et 4
degrés nous voulions justement permettre
de valoriser les talents du territoire
mais aussi d'ailleurs
à travers différentes thématiques 18
exposants ont répondu présent à l'appel
et les visiteurs et est au rendez vous
on est curieuse et donc nous sommes
venus pour activer attirés par la
curiosité comme un petit enfant de 4 ans
on a voulu lui faire découvrir et puis
faire des activités un peu éducative
avec lui les enfants pouvaient même
s'exercer lors d'ateliers de quoi
planter des idées dans ces petites
graines d'inventeurs